[Música]
empecé a estudiar ecología con la idea
de tratar de encontrar respuestas a los
problemas que existen entre las
sociedades humanas y la naturaleza sin
embargo para mi sorpresa me encontré con
un principio
imagínense el precipicio ahí
en vez de encontrar respuestas habitaba
la filosofía imagínense la y en el fondo
y ahí estaba lleno de preguntas que
tenían que ver con la ecología y que
hace miles de años que estaban ahí
esperando por ejemplo hace 2500 años uno
de mis filósofos favoritos anaximandro
se preguntó que somos yo me lo imagino
mirando las estrellas
somos
una porción de materia y energía que le
pidió prestado al universo
un instante de identidad
a mí me parece increíble y si hoy
sabemos
que todos los elementos que fluyen por
nuestro cuerpo y que fluyen por todos
lados y por todas las cosas fueron
fabricados en el interior de las
estrellas guau hace 2500 años esos
sabios estaban en lo cierto entonces voy
a tomar esto como punto de partida y esa
porción de materia y energía se la vamos
a pedir prestada máxima dentro del
precipicio filosófico la vamos a poner
acá y lo vamos a llamar el stock
primordial
ahora voy a pedir prestado una pintura a
mi hija mayor a na
dónde vamos a imaginarnos que los
humanos en su evolución
pasaron de esa materia y energía
transformando cosas estructuras en lo
que algunos de mont denominarían cultura
por supuesto que la cultura
es mucho más que eso pero yo lo que
quiero denotar es esa dependencia que
tenemos de ese stock primordial que está
aquí para transformar esa cultura que la
pongo de este lado ahora para
transformar esa
materia
en cultura necesitamos algo que también
había dicho anaximandro en los términos
que usaríamos que es energía
necesitamos potencia para transformar
una cosa en la otra entonces cómo estoy
usando energía y potencia voy a usar una
palabra que me gusta más que está en
inglés que es power porque significa
potencia significa energía y también
significa poder entonces voy a usar la
palabra power en todos esos sentidos en
todo el abanico semántico de la palabra
energía potencia poder incluyendo el
poder político
los humanos al principio y acá miro la
hermosa pintura de anna se manejaban con
poco powers tenían que arreglarse con lo
que tenían en su entorno para construir
su lugar en el mundo
ahora con el tiempo cuando aparecieron
los combustibles fósiles el carbón el
petróleo el gasto y largo etcétera
ese power se multiplicó al punto de que
pudieron sobrepasar la capacidad de lo
que tenían a su alrededor e incluso
devastar lo deteriorado y es más usar
ese enorme power para ir a otros sitios
remotos y apropiarse de recursos
naturales de otras sociedades y de otros
continentes y convertirse en por ejemplo
una super power una superpotencia a
expensas de usar recursos de otras
sociedades
ahora bien
esas
poder de transformación de este stock
primordial energía lo podemos ver a
nivel individuo y puedo otra vez ir a
ese precipicio filosófico y preguntarme
claro nosotros podemos usar eso para ser
lo que podamos ser cada individuo de
este planeta podría usar ese power con
el que nace para hacer lo que quiera
hacer entonces otra vez vuelvo a la
pintura de mi hija anna donde la caen
que ejemplificamos que todo lo que
nosotros soñamos ser son esas flores que
vuelan por la cabeza ahora la pregunta
es
qué es lo que podemos ser bueno podemos
ser todo lo que nos permite nuestro
libre albedrío podemos ser todo lo que
hemos soñado ser y bueno depende no
todos nacemos con el privilegio de
llegar a elegir lo que se nos ocurre
hacer por ejemplo
una mala salud
un mal salario una mala educación y un
largo etcétera etcétera etcétera
etcétera
nos limita a una marginalidad que a
veces ni siquiera nos permite sobrevivir
esto si nosotros imaginamos que este
stock primordial que tengo acá
es un capital que debemos repartirlo
para que cada uno de nosotros tenga por
lo menos una línea de base que nos
permita hacer lo que queremos ser
si un individuo o una sociedad
o un país o una nación o un continente o
una civilización toma más de ese stock
de lo que le corresponde
del otro lado lo que está ocurriendo es
una marginalidad equivalente
matemáticamente a un genocidio a un
crimen de lesa humanidad porque aumenta
la mortalidad infantil ni siquiera es
posible pensar en sobrevivir en muchos
de los casos entonces aquí llegamos a
otro punto filosófico
esa es la ética que el poder escrito
para nosotros entonces yo creo que lo
que tenemos que hacer es hacerla de goma
la ética y una vez que hacemos de goma
estirar la estirarla tanto tanto tanto
que si se rompe señoras y señores y
bueno vamos a tener que hacer otra vamos
a tener que inventar otra ética entre
todos nosotros por lo menos más
inclusiva
el problema es que la sociedad actual la
economía clásica como les llaman es una
imposibilidad termodinámica les voy a
explicar que quiero decir con esto
imaginemos que este estado primordial
que ustedes lo siguen viendo acá por
supuesto porque tengo un holograma no lo
vamos a tratar como si fuera un capital
algunos lo llaman el capital natural ese
capital natural por supuesto genera
intereses los bosques crecen los peces
se reproducen y en la medida en que
nosotros vivamos de sus intereses
consumamos menos de lo que el bosque
crece por año con consumos menos peces
de los que se reproducen por años
podríamos vivir indefinidamente desde
capital natural que eso es más o menos
lo que los científicos llamamos
sustentabilidad
ahora bien
cuando les parece a ustedes
y la economía humana que la sociedad
global va a llegar a un momento donde ya
no podamos vivir de los intereses que
genera el capital natural y empecemos a
comernos el capital empecemos a fundir
nos
mirándolo en términos financieros cuando
les parece que el planeta va a decir
basta no los banco más el año que viene
el año 2050 el año 3000 bueno yo les voy
a dar una fecha proveniente de un
estudio muy serio que se hizo en 1978
a partir de esa fecha ya no es posible
hablar de desarrollo sustentable como
hablamos los científicos sabrán los
políticos se hablan en foros
internacionales ningún país lo está
cumpliendo creo que es el momento de
empezar a hablar de desarrollo con un
retroceso razonable en vez de desarrollo
sustentable tenemos que hablar de
retroceso razonable entonces así estamos
hemos habitado poéticamente la tierra
hasta ahora claro que no como salimos de
esa situación
hay algunos escritores como uno que
elegido recientemente yuval no hará
alguien en el libro o modelos que
plantean unos dos escenarios posibles
que se escapan para arriba
escapar para arriba significa a partir
de mucho dinero tecnología interface
ciencia inteligencia artificial la ayuda
de la medicina ultra moderna manufactura
molecular y un enorme paquete carísimo
tecnológico que los hombres pueden
convertirse en súper humanos
en dios es prácticamente inmortal es
súper inteligentes ahora la pregunta es
cuántos también son fenómenos pero
cuántos siete mil millones como somos
ahora nueve mil millones como vamos a
hacer en 2050 a no no no unos pocos los
que tengan la capacidad económica lo que
tengan el power concentrado como para
tener acceso a esta tecnología bueno yo
creo que es es una idea muy peligroso
tal vez sea la idea más peligrosa del
mundo
porque debería de hablar de super
humanos a razas superiores y a razas
inferiores hay un pasito así que el
autor no lo dio pero hay un solo pasito
así y ya sabemos si leemos un poco la
historia en qué desastre ha terminado
esa idea
creo que hay que ir
en sentido contrario no a convertirnos
en dioses sino a ir hacia abajo
usando también la tecnología pero
adecuándonos a un planeta que ya no se
está quedando chico y no por una
cuestión demográfica sino por la
cuestión de redistribución entonces ese
retroceso razonable implica por encima
de todas las cosas que la economía
humana que las leyes de las naciones se
subordinen
a las leyes naturales no queda otra será
doloroso pero ese es el único camino
posible para que la gran mayoría de
nosotros pueda habitar este planeta
ahora el problema principal es bueno es
deporte porque no lo hacemos entonces
vuelo al abismo filosófico y la pregunta
es por qué somos así
ese es el tema principal el problema es
como somos
un filósofo muy conocido hegel dijo que
la lucha por el reconocimiento es el
motor que mueve el mundo pero podemos
agregar llevando la ecología que esa
lucha por el reconocimiento es lo que
nos ha llevado a la catástrofe que
tenemos hoy entonces uno poder puede
preguntarse claro qué tienen que hacer
los gobiernos que tenemos que hacer
nosotros
luchar por reconocer significa de alguna
manera en nuestra vida actual consumir
para ser reconocidos para aparentar más
de lo que somos entonces cuál es la meta
que nos reconozcan por lo que no somos
no será mejor tomar por un atajo y
apuntar directamente a ser queridos en
vez de a ser reconocidos a ser amados a
amar a ser amados a construir en
conjunto un lugar amado
claro pero entonces qué tiene que ver la
felicidad el amor con la ecología tiene
mucho que ver porque a mí me parece y
esa es la idea que les quiero tirar que
una persona amada y feliz tiene una
huella más delicada sobre el planeta
necesita consumir menos y está llenar
menos ese vacío que hoy llenamos con el
consumo hoy la ostentación es un
indicador de prestigio en la lucha por
los conocimientos nosotros tenemos la
batalla la batalla de invertir ese
indicador de prestigio y de que la
ostentación sea una vergüenza entonces
ahí vamos a empezar a acomodarnos en el
planeta ahora cómo saber si estamos en
lo ecológicamente correcto aprobamos en
otro
filósofo kant que nos dijo bueno para
saber si estoy en lo correcto o no debo
preguntarme si todo el mundo hace lo que
hago yo cómo sería el mundo entonces eso
es lo que les quiero dejar
piensen cuando salgan de acá cuando se
reúnan con los demás en la búsqueda de
ese camino de la felicidad que todos los
gobiernos deberían garantizar cómo sería
el mundo si todos hacen lo que hago yo
entonces la pregunta que les quiero
dejar ya que no les he dejado ninguna
respuesta
cómo
debemos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]